[Music]
yeah my levels it's funny my levels keep
defaulting to like minus
42 hey you did you just turn it up that
sounds better I can hear you better 42
isn't that the meaning of life yeah yeah
I did oh does that sound better now it
sounds better what whatever you just did
to it for us I just on but that's so
strange why would my audacity levels imp
the levels on Zoom it wasn't really
quiet it was just quieter okay okay cool
good let's let's start for the uh the
listeners out here pill pod
154 we were covering the Liberals end of
history and almost nobody is happy with
that including the Liberals not
particularly at least uh
fukiyama but just to catch everyone up
history's over because because despite
any rhetorical oppositions you may have
or even anti- liberal ground swells in a
few places dotted throughout the globe
or anti- capitalist ground swells
throughout the globe there's ultimately
no serious alternative to mostly free
markets in states with some liberal
rights peppered in so we got rights to
vote rights to speak about most things
and that's pretty much the best we can
manage for the foreseeable future
unfortunately and
indefinitely so revolution's always just
going to be Beyond the Horizon and
global capitalism has proved that it's
uh adaptable enough to deal with most of
the crises that it itself creates so we
read Francis fukiyama over three
episodes and he uses some I think we can
say some bizarre and just sometimes
terribly myopic oversimplified reasons
for how we arrived at our current status
quo but despite his weird Wagon Trail we
all have to admit I think that we are
all in some degree fukiyama
ists surprisingly it was not actually
something that I even expected and I'd
read it before or i' read parts of it
before I am curious pills uh what was
the reaction from the patrons uh to like
our whole series well the one that I can
remember offand is the liberal Vibes are
strong with this one with this episode
or with me no no no with the episode oh
yeah well listen we kind of all agreed
that you may not like it but until like
Germany and invades France again or
Trump abolishes private property this is
this is the world we live in so another
phrasing that is more uh palatable maybe
to leftists is that the end of History
means it's a lot easier to imagine the
end of the world than the end of
capitalism that's kind of even fama's
Point rather than all of the
characterized versions of him despite
how much bad [__] and wrong [__] and
straight up revisionist [__] that he
says and those those catastrophic events
didn't even affect his thesis anyway
like the fall of the Roman Empire is
still there's still progress culture
restarts and then reaches Heights that
Rome never reached so there's still
progress there sorry I should mention i'
I'm recovering from a severe illness
this week and I'm going to be a little
bit lowkey why be so vague about it it
was just covid man yeah if you say
severe illness I feel like that sounds
scarier than Co yeah of course we all
got it that's true that's true yeah I
had I had the Corona virus the sun is
this your your number two or your number
three I I've lost count I think it must
be number three yeah I had it three
times I don't know third was the worst
for me yeah the cold sweats that's not
that doesn't sound fun yeah I was in a
water bed all week just soaked yeah yeah
that happened to me one of the times too
well we can we can speak of 911 we can
speak of Co are these real events that
give an alternative to the current order
not really they lead to the same
consolidation right I guess people
thought maybe Co would lead to
Alternatives I remember people were even
kind of talking about that they're like
look at all the stimulus money that
they're giving it's like maybe this is
showing that it's possible to have like
Ubi but would Ubi even be a genuine
event I mean I don't know I think you
could see it through the lens of
fukiyama as just a further elaboration
of the of the of the values of like
liberal democracy or something of just
like cementing you know some kind of
social safety net for maintaining the
status quo well the thing with the the
thing with the covid payouts like
businesses and large businesses got more
of a payout than the average family got
which if everyone's getting the same
payout ultimately you're losing the
value of the money that you're being
given economy
stimulus that's what it's aimed at now
just to offset the uh criticism that
will no doubt come the marxists and the
anarchists will they'll still tell you
no bro it's just the contradictions wait
for it but if we ignore the 15 of them
for a second sorry we thought for today
that it would be fun to Horseshoe Theory
this [__] yeah so we went to the
conservative side and these these weirdo
christs following uh Catholic
conservatives they are also not happy
about the end of History so if you
object to the end of History
marxists and if you want to make a deal
with the devil we have found a team that
agrees with you here they are Catholic
conservatives yeah totally they're um I
was actually just looking behind me for
uh one of the more recent books that
also I think speaks to a rejection of
the end of History thesis which is
Patrick Den's uh uh the what do he
called it oh like why liberalism failed
right and like that's very much a
conservative critique of and you know to
be honest to to to the credit and this
sort of lends Credence to your horseshoe
Theory thematization here because in
that book you know he spends a lot of
time actually saying really nasty
Justified nasty things about capitalism
and all and all the ways that it
destroys you know social life uh so so
there's so like I think the post-
Liberals of Patrick Denine you know he
actually very much adopts a kind of
something that has a family resemblance
with Marxist critique of
capitalism critique is he a is he
Catholic yes he is Catholic very much so
at Notre Dam University yeah I mean his
thesis is like essentially that
liberalism has its own it's it's like a
contradictory sort of argument about
like internal contradictions within
liberalism that he says that like
liberalism sort of creates the
conditions of its own destruction
because of its it's the ways that it
basically erodes social and moral values
and economizes everything and basically
like extracts meaning from life and he
definitely has like a religious spin on
it but it is like very much in that
theme of oh it's digging its own grave
because it's destroying all values and
and it's actually not that different
from sort of what fukiyama says about
the last man except it it's has an even
darker spin to the last man right it's
like saying that that's actually
ultimately going to be a destruction of
it and that's also why like I don't
think that fukiyama thesis is as Triumph
and as it seems he's you know he's just
saying it's going in this direction but
like is it's it's an open question of
whether like people are going to be
happier right just going to be more
secure but happier I don't know could I
suggest a different framing than
horseshoe though because you know
horseshoe Theory yeah yeah yeah well
hear me out because we haven't really
given the left a hearing like fukiyama
is not representing the left side of the
horseshoe no no no no no the I'm I'm
saying no fukiyama is right in the
middle of the Horseshoe I'm saying f
fukiyama is the center of the Horseshoe
he's center right and now we've looked
now we've styed a little farther to the
right so this is more like fish hook
Theory where one side is curving around
we don't know what the other side is
doing because we haven't done the
leftist take on the end of History yet I
wouldn't put fukiyama there as the
representative of the left side of the
Horseshoe that seems a little crazy to
me no no the marxists are the left side
the marxists and the anarchists who are
like look at the zapatistas this is the
we should be following yeah I love it
they love the zapatistas I think we
would have to maybe substantialize how
Marxism is what we're going to be
talking about is somehow coinciding with
what Marxist would say about the end of
History I've seen what I've seen what
like David Harvey says about this stuff
and it's very different I mean we can
flate all the time
conservatism and the rightwing but this
is the first time in recent memory this
is the first time in recent memory that
I actually read straight up
conservatives that are like this was all
better 300 years ago so they're not
historicists but they are historical
lists in that history is good and the
further we get from it the worse off we
are and reading this [__] not blowing on
the progress trumpet so hard true true
yeah there it's all about regress we
used to watch great films like Lord of
the Rings and now we watch [__] films
like Disney that are making your kids
get we're going to introduce our sources
but reading this [__] makes me miss it
makes me miss haiger you know cuz sure
he was a
Nazi mystical but at least he was an
interesting conservative like these
these shits are the the intellectual
right but I don't like I'm not seeing
the intellect I spent hours on this
website and they're mostly just whining
about Disney movies and whining that the
kids are on Tik Tok instead of going to
a Biblical hermeneutics class like
everybody used to do I suppose and just
getting married and having five kids
that's what they should be doing exactly
you should be putting your five kids to
bed each with their copy of The
Chronicles of Narnia they're on Tik Tok
instead of that anyway who are we
talking about I found this Gem of a
website I was doing research for
something else and I stumbled across it
it's called The imaginative
conservative.org so I sent you guys a
few articles but yeah I spent I spent a
long time they do how many Artic did you
read they do movie reviews they do like
current events reviews surprisingly not
a single word about Israel but it's a
it's a little self-referential Universe
dedicated to making the West great again
I think with
Catholicism but I guess yeah I guess we
didn't try hard enough with Catholicism
the first time so we have to we have to
have another Christianity is like their
first drop I noticed that um one of the
authors of I think there's like two
articles that talk about the end of
history that I read and I think one of
them um one of them said like something
about how he was referencing some other
Catholic thinkers and I think he says
despite them being Catholic they have
the most interesting things to say so
that made me at least that led me to
believe at least that the guy who was
writing here was like actually more of a
Protestant of some kind see if find the
place let me see if I can find where he
says it uh let me see if it was on this
one because a a lot of the Protestant
quote unquote intellectuals they they
valorize Catholic intellectuals they
just can't they can't make the jump they
can't make the
leap I feel like this this is something
I've noticed tangentially a few times
like my parents are friends with this um
history Professor who's retired now for
a while he was teaching at
um at uh like what's it called there's
like this Christian Protestant School in
Toronto like a university Tindale
Tindale yeah part of UF right exactly or
no it's not part of UFT it's like it's
actually its own independent private
school Oh I thought it was connected and
he was teaching there and it's funny
when he retired I was like he was
visiting my parents and and he was like
oh I became a Catholic I like after that
and I was like oh really I was like
interesting he's like I'm like what like
why like do you mind if I ask why and
we'd had little debates about like Youth
and Asian abortion in the past like he's
just we have like discussions about that
stuff and he obviously takes the more
Christian Perspective and it was it was
just funny to me that like right after
he left his teaching post at a
Protestant University he was like okay
I'm Catholic now and then I was like
trying to figure out why like why I was
like could you just explain it to me
he's like well it's really complicated
but I guess I guess the answer would be
because I want to be able to participate
in the body of Christ you can't do that
with like uh rock bands and like
overhead projector concerts and you you
can't do that with like boring with
boring protestantism I guess okay let me
read the about page of this website the
imaginative conservative is an
online and note online has a dash in the
middle it's on dash
line an online journal for those who
seek the true the good and the Beautiful
by noted Catholic philosophy oper Plato
we address culture liberal learning
politics political economy literature
and the Arts and the American Republic
in the tradition of Russell Kirk TS
Elliott Edmund Burke Irving babbit
Wilhelm ripy Robert Nisbet Richard
Weaver Emmy Bradford Eric vogan
Christopher Dawson Paul Elmer Moore and
other leaders of imaginative
conservatism so I don't know who most of
those people are
except for TS Elliott and Edmund Burke
but I do also know one of the names on
this list which is Eric vogan because he
made
this fun let let's say fun interesting
claim that Marxism and Nazism are both
modern-day gnosticism and modern day
gnosticism is the real threat so if you
guys have heard of that's the hor if you
guys have heard of this very uh let's
call him self assured Twitter user James
Lindsay I guess this is his uh Source
material so what is gnosticism for vogan
you may ask well Marxism communism
national socialism progressivism
liberalism and
humanism leaves you wondering what's not
nosism yeah that's the Horseshoe theory
if you go far enough to the left far
enough to the right you end up in the
same place exactly Gnostic Gnostic
apparently which is which is strange
because that's something very
specific because they're imaginative
conservatives I got to say it's quite
imaginative to just say that anything
you don't like is identical to a loose
group of like fourth Century mystery
Cults that's some pretty it's it's fun
[__] do do you want to Define do you
want to Define gnosticism just to give
the listener I I have no idea how he
defines ticism no no but could you Eric
or just like how it's traditionally
understood well gnosticism were like
basically neoplatonic Cults sorry I'm
not Eric but they're like neoplatonic
but not really Christian and the
Christians defin them I think in
probably about the 3 Century they Define
them as Heretics and they use Jesus
quite often but they deny the
materiality of Jesus because one of the
core parts of gnosticism is that the
world was created by a fallen God rather
than the the perfect good God so the
world that we live in is created by the
Demi urge which is also the god of the
Old Testament and we're trapped we're
trapped here in this material cage and
then outside of the world somewhere is
uh
Sophia the true wisdom and basically the
M the world you look around you see and
it's evil I think it also is like a hot
a mixture of Jewish and cabala and kind
of apocryphal
apocryphal teachings and that there's
secret messages in religious literature
that can be decoded I mean it's there's
some pretty cool stuff there but it's
being used obviously like that's
specific historical understanding of it
this this way of using it is just to use
it as like a yeah use it condescendingly
use it as a
slur it's actually quite cool this is
imaginative I'll I'll give that to them
but I think the issue that he has with
narcissism this Eric vogan guy is that
it it assumes that humans can fix the
world based on their own efforts which
is his problem
with Marxism leftism liberalism it's
like you need the Transcendent to rescue
you from the world or to redeem the
world but humans can't do this on their
own which is why liberalism is also a
form of gnosticism yeah secret secret
teachings and there's also some there's
some fun [__] on this website man like
the the movie review section the only
movies that they like unsurprisingly are
Gran Torino and Lord of the
Rings gr gr the the review for
Oppenheimer is titled A Cry For Truth in
the
Wasteland guess they didn't like
it they have a whole bunch of tenets
right I only I only copied down the
first two but their tenets are first
number one the conservative believes
that there exists an enduring moral
order that order is made for man and man
is made for it human nature is a
constant and moral truths are permanent
and then second the conservative adheres
to custom convention and
continuity it is old custom that enables
people to live together peaceably the
Destroyers of
custom I.E the woke left demolish more
than they know or
[Music]
desire the opposite of all those is just
liberalism then yeah so you can see why
they would oppose the end of History
because we're on a slow de line towards
you know the death of the things that
they think are important which
is we listen to Du alipa instead of
chovsky yeah what was this uh what was
this original article that you sent us
the demolition of the western mind
there's there's so many articles about
the death of the West which is why I
thought it appropriate to bring up on a
end of History because they're trying to
stop the decline I guess yeah well I
remember when you sent that to me and
you said something about the end of
history and I read through it and I was
like that's weird I was like what is
this article I mean it's funny but what
does this article have to do with the
end of history and then I Google or I
searched within the website and then I
saw that there were at least two other
articles about the end of history and
read those but I mean it's pretty I
guess this this article is mostly him
going through stuff that CS Lewis wrote
in like
some uh one of his books the screw tape
letters is that right have you read that
I have I think it's um it's a the devil
is talking to a different devil and
there it's how to trick Humanity into
believing it's kind of like that um the
the greatest trick the de devil ever
pulled was to convince Humanity that it
doesn't exist that kind of thing right
and he and he takes a bunch of quotes
from it uh he talks about like same-sex
marriage and like other stuff as being
signs
of uh you know Decay the fall of Western
culture in the second tenet custom
convention and continuity so it's like
if you're going to change anything
change it really slow our ancestors
should have a vote you know like there's
a reason that things are the way they
are that is not arbitrary so conserve
the history oh yeah and he's also
they're also reviewing some book by oh
it's actually a book review right okay
my bad sex in the unreal City the
demolition of the western Mind by
Anthony esselin on ignacius press who's
a Ivy League trained person who then
took up working for private Catholic
colleges in the
states classic career path for
right-wing cultural commentators of a
Catholic persuasion and this is the guy
you were thinking of he's an Evangelical
Protestant who
admires conservative Catholic critics
quite a lot like he's one of those
Protestants that is so conservative he's
like oh I might as well have just been
been born Catholic wish I what did he
called him a cradle Catholic it's weird
terminology yeah he says quoting him
from the article he says although I am
an Evangelical most of my favorite
conservative cultural critics Joseph
Pierce Peter creft Thomas Howard Holly
Ordway Dwight long Necker and the late
Richard John new house I think that's
the only one I've heard of not to
mention Chesterton and Cardinal Newman
are Catholic converts okay so wait these
are all people who weren't Catholic but
became Catholic so that's kind of funny
it's like he's setting himself up to be
like that'll probably be me soon as a
cradle Catholic Dr wrestling brings
brings with him a deep sense of
rootedness imagination knows no bounds
exactly exactly the the importance that
rootedness reverberates oh it's just
haiger hi haiger was raised a Catholic
so yeah he was a he was a tomisic
scholar he's a really really good one
from what I hear but while we're talking
about history I don't I know if you guys
know about this cuz I don't but I I want
to figure it out because I don't really
get it because Christianity has this
very weird relationship with history in
terms of its metaphysics
and I don't find it really consistent
and I'm going to probably get called out
for this by people who know more than I
do but I did take I did take a a
religious studies history cross list
course in grad school but it seems to me
like we got the old the Old Testament
it's called the old for a reason it's
the old Covenant but for all intents and
purposes that kind of is saying you know
none of this background really matters
except for Christ because Christ
replaced the [__] and the past is
replaced even for us today at a a
physical location in time and space like
in our world it's not exterior to our
world it's first Century Roman Empire
Palestine so what I don't get is Christ
always existed right then he comes from
outside of history and then dies and
then goes back to outside of history and
yet we're all here doing stuff for some
reason like waiting for him to come back
I guess is it isn't that already the end
of history that nothing we do actually
matters after 30 ad that's protestantism
that's more like what John Calvin and
the predestination people believe that
you can't actually you can't know but
you can't actually change whether you're
going to be saved or condemned in
Judgment Day that's like yeah
Calvinism no because the C Catholicism
has to have that whole apparatus of the
church to decide and you know you have
the kind of extra biblical baggage like
purgatory and IND indulgences and things
like that in the whole church hierarchy
but what is the purpose like I've read
Augustine city of God but beyond that
what's the purpose of the church in
history is it to like make the whole
world Christian and why does it have to
make the whole world Christian because
Christ is going to come back and like
judge everyone anyway right there's a
final there's a final judgment oh
they're the temporal church that they
started out as the king makers when
started crowning Kings of Northern
Europe with Charlamagne in 800
ad and it was a political entity I mean
it's hard to say like why does it exist
I don't know St Peter gave the keys to
the Roman Catholics and they've passed
them down I'm not asking that I'm asking
what is the metaphysical purpose is it
just like the purpose of history is just
so people can live a life and figure out
who's going to heaven and who's not
going to heaven is that the city of God
yeah sort sort the Sinners or or is it
to change history is it to find out who
goes to heaven or is it to change the
world into the image of the city of
God it's like to turn the world into a
assembly line of of good Christian Souls
I I don't know man I mean they had their
shot they had like they had their shot
in the Middle Ages so if that's what we
want to return to as imaginative
conservatives then go for it all the
corruption really [__] them up and
Protestant split they can't carry out
their mission properly anymore it's so
sad that's why they want to go back to
Catholics these conservative Protestants
I I do have another metaphysical
question about Christianity if you die
and there's like heaven but Heaven as we
know it I don't I don't think it's in
the Bible it's like invented in the
Middle Ages by like Dante and people but
do you go to heaven when you die or do
you have to wait till the final judgment
because there is
that and then it like Heaven's probably
outside of
History wait is the final is the final
judgment in the Bible like I'm by the
way I'm like an extremely unchristian
grew up in an atheist family so like I
probably have like less than no
education like so I knew that heaven and
hell were kind of like a an in an
invention that doesn't appear in the
Bible at all but does final judgment
appear in the Bible
I think it's a it's a revelation thing
the second coming yeah the apocalypse
but also Jesus himself says like the
Master's coming and he's going to
separate the sheep from the goats that
kind of thing okay yeah Judgment day but
like if if Heaven's outside of time when
you
die did everyone actually just die at
exactly the same time like even though
Augustine died 2,000 years ago if you
get to heaven because it's outside of
time did he also just get there I mean
how the hell am I supposed to know that
I'm trying to I'm trying to figure out
the mechanics well I want to get in
there you can ask those questions with
like well where does free will come from
why is there evil you know like what was
Augustine's answer to the Free Will
question was almost like you can say it
like a metaphor like God kind of inhaled
and like left a little bit of space in
the universe for free
choice and that's like and then in there
you have temporality too it's weird to
think of yeah there's no time in
eternity so everything's just sort of
all there and then now there's this sort
of temporal space where events have to
pass in order and there's a future and a
past and the present and the Catholic
church is the temporal manifestation of
Christian
values and you have all this problem of
then reconciling that with eternity so I
guess if it's a temp I'm trying to
figure out the metaphysical question
here because this would tell me what
Christians think history is for if it's
not over because these These Guys these
Catholic uh whatever imaginative
conservatives what they think makes time
worth it is are you watching Lord of the
Rings which is a good movie because I
don't know [__] Aragon is Jesus or
something or are you bad and watching
woke disy disy um Pro promoting a sexual
agenda for children which is an article
I read on this website which is a gold M
so what is the purpose of being alive is
it just to see if you can get into
heaven or are you supposed to be
changing the world it's a test run it's
a test run to see how you do yeah like
yeah I mean it's if it's atemporal that
is an interesting question the more I
thought about it well then presumably
it's true because if it's like outside
of time then yeah like you would think
that everyone would just get there at
the same time because there is no so
like they would all be there already
like or something right like or or you'd
all be there at the same time this makes
Calvinism make some sense to me because
if it is outside of time you are already
there if you made it right yeah if you
made it you're already there right just
like so you'd be I wish I knew you were
going to ask this because then I would
have read Augustine's confessions has a
whole section on temporality at the end
his philosophy of time and what it's for
that's a good section great actually
here's like a little Star Trek reference
to come in if anyone's seen uh I think
it was the first Star Trek movie to
feature the cast of Star Trek the Next
Generation Star Trek generations I
believe it's called Uh and it was
notable notably not a very good movie
but also notable for having Captain Kirk
and John lard meet and like beat some
bad guy together but there's a whole sub
plot about this thing called the Nexus
that people are trying to chase and get
into and basically like when you get
there it's like basically like all your
like unfulfilled memories like all the
things that you want it's basically like
a heaven kind of that you'd imagine it
but like it's funny I'm what's making me
think of it is like I remember that the
scene where Jean Luke Picard gets pulled
into the Nexus and finds Captain Kirk
Captain Kirk is like I just got here and
uh Jean luk Bard's like oh like you've
been dead for like 80 or 90 years years
or whatever right so anyway I think the
Nexus clearly if we see the Nexus as an
analogy or or like a sort of a PL I
don't know what the right word is I
guess a kind of like a riff on heaven
then I mean they seem to think that yeah
it would be outside of time so everyone
would feel like they got there at the
same time which is exactly what's
depicted in the movie like Sean lard
shows up and he meets Captain Kirk and
he's like I just got here it's like so
did I so but then also Jesus wouldn't
know that he's taking so long to get
back cuz he should have been like in the
first century
ad Christians were so convinced that
Christ was going to return that they
were like quitting their jobs and [__]
and we've seen this repeated like with
multiple Cults I think the Adventists
did something like this but no Jesus is
coming back on this day you can quit
your job you can rack up some credit
card debt real quick Max of your credit
cards yeah that's the best one I guess
you you'd have to erase your own memory
and then wake up in temporal land where
things are imperfect and linear because
up there in space before you know they
discovered that the laws down here apply
up there they thought everything was
perfect and round and circular and
repeatable and
eternal and then down here in the
sublunar zone everything was kind of
corruptible
and you know one thing after another
temporality kind of anyway what do we do
as imaginative
conservatives so for them I I I guess
they haven't thought about any of this
but Western Civilization is being lost
it's in the process of dying so they
quietly accept I think that history is
ending but they're going to return and
like
museumification instead of Disney can I
just say to you like the two articles
that specifically T reference fukiyama
as the end of history I mean I don't
know if we you want to move to that yet
um but I mean it was just striking to me
like the fact that all of us are fresh
off of actually engaging with that text
like how much it's obvious that they
didn't read it you know like I mean but
no one read it but still like it's
extremely obviously they didn't read it
um you know there's a bunch of stuff in
there that they say that like is just
just not I mean I don't want to like
quibble with like boring points but like
it's just very obvious and I think one
of the things they say is like oh
fukiyama thinks America is the best and
he wants the whole world to be America
but like fukiyama is definitely pretty
clear that like America is not what he
had in mind about uh the end of history
and you know James Madison and all this
stuff I don't know it's kind of funny
well I wanted to float this because it
looks it they make it appear like they
are actually looking backwards into
history but of course history doesn't
move backwards so they're looking into a
fantasy a nostalgic fantasy that they've
presented about history as the future
and I think that they would even say
this too that we can move forward into a
more Christ centered
culture um where we paint pictures of
Jesus like Da Vinci did instead of
painting Soup cans and this is a a a
symbol of Decay and degradation but they
fear the end of History and they want
history they want history to be
conserved except in this Museum way like
we read this really funny article about
the book and the guy is just ranting
about how books are dying and he he
says Kindles will never replicate the
smell of an old book and that this kind
of [__] but I'm just confused again to
the logic of this like God intervenes
presumably by saving the world from sin
he sends
Jesus or God I don't know Jesus sends
himself I guess but then like he didn't
do very well if we need this website to
exist why do you need to save the world
if the world's already saved and
history's over because they they aren't
happy about any of this stuff
so is their purpose just to then
preserve a museum of intellectual
Curiosities until God comes back and
finishes the job cuz they're boning the
end of history as we all do but I don't
know what they think their purpose is
here well I think they
also attend to their own salvation and
stop worrying so much about everyone
else's that that seems reasonable
doesn't it like go focus on your life
instead of bitching about Disney and Tik
Tok yeah but Christians that's what
makes Christians so annoying is they're
just so obsessed with converting
everyone if the end of history is coming
and it's Judgment Day and you're
sufficiently prepared you believe you've
done all you can to you know stick to
the ways of the Bible and and live a
life free of sin and be forgiven of the
original sin of Adam and Eve and all
that sort of thing then what do you have
to what are you so worried about like
why are you worried whether they're like
the new Lord of the Rings has people of
color in it like why is that so [__]
grading on your sensibilities just
yourself and your own soul oh I I should
have stipulated they like the original
Lord of the Rings movies they don't like
the new
one oh yeah of course of course I could
have no like the series The Cartoon
Series Oh you mean the show on prime or
something like that yeah also that's why
I love Jews so much because I just love
that they are just like yeah like we're
the chosen people and like we don't want
you and I'm like great I don't want I
don't want to be that either it's like I
they just I love the non proling it's my
favorite it's one of my favor
things well this is what's so
interesting about history right like you
can go back in time and be like okay
like in
1492 you know Queen Isabella gave this
decree and said all the Jews can either
leave Europe or convert to Christianity
and you can then start asking these
historical questions like why was this
happening now in this time in 1492 the
same year that Columbus discovered you
know the new world and the same year
that also the Moors were finally like
kicked out of Europe the the Muslim
strong last Muslim stronghold in Europe
fell to the Spanish rulers like you can
ask those questions but when we're just
doing this sort of like vague cultural
commentating fear mongering stuff
there's no truth anymore it's all just
like smoke and mirrors and people's
opinions and I don't like this
development this development good it's
it's all such [__] like I love the
historic I love the history of it like
like the Jews were persecuted in history
like why is that and what are the
consequences that we continue to live
with because of that prejudice and
persecution but but like the level of
argument that the these kinds of
websites have is like you can't there's
no evidence or like basis for making
claims at all it's all just they make
all kinds of outlandish claims yeah it's
all just and people fall for it it's
that seduction effect again like people
fall into it and get sucked in and it's
immersive well because they have
I feel like what's what happens too is
like people have a vague sense of just
like how they don't like the way Society
is and then if someone can just speak to
that vague feeling they just get seduced
by something like this but I do love the
part um and I think the first uh the end
of History the end of the end of History
article where like he's talking
about uh Biden and the Democrats and
he's just like he's basically saying oh
fukiyama is wrong because like look at
China and like a bunch of other stuff
which anyway setting aside like why that
doesn't necessarily um you know uh
invalidate fukuyama's thesis forget
about that
but um now he says actually this threat
has been growing for a good while now um
but at this historical moment the United
States seems poised to make shall we say
its own Great Leap Forward referencing
China that would be a leap in the
direction of Chinese style centralized
government and one party Rule and this
is written in 2021 by the way right
after Biden was elected at least that
seems to be what the uni what a unified
Democratic party is poised to attempt
the margin of power is close but the
will to act is there and many others
many other pieces are in place Donald
Trump may be gone but that will not be
enough so I just like love how they're
just all of the sudden because Biden won
they're like oh like the Democrats are
trying
to to impose one party rule literally
right after Trump just tried to steal
the ction this was less than a month
after January
6th and they're just like yeah the real
threats the Democratic party like trying
to cement Chinese style communism like
what motivates these kinds of statements
it's like how does this how does any of
this affect the purity of your moral
soul and your salvation like they need
to do some uh some serious Loyola
spiritual exercises and and try to get
back in touch with their spirituality
because because it seems like they're
confused and angry and they don't why
does this why do these temporal events
affect your salvation is my question and
and and these these sort of petty
politics that in a thousand years going
to be like footnotes and history books
God I wish we could invite one of these
writers on the podcast to like to
interrogate them and just be like what's
like could you could you like try to
settle some of these metaphysical
questions about your belief systems cuz
like I'm trying to buy in but it's just
not making sense you know they just love
like the
Renaissance I guess because it's
Christian art but they don't go on about
the Dignity of man too much do they well
yeah they don't go on about the feudal
order in which the those works of art
were were created either but okay I'll
get I'll give you a long- winded quote
this is uh one of their articles about
the left why celebrities leave the
left no dream the right has an advantage
over the left in this field they it does
not have to present an abstract vision
of the Future IT offers the security of
a return to a past Christian order the
left May hate and distort this order but
it cannot deny its existence and
verifiable claims the Christian order
points to a highly attractive or points
to highly attractive historical
accomplishments cultural developments
and heroic Feats conservatives can have
recourse to the memories of happier
times the left's memories of past
utopian nightmares like communism are
not so happy the the lack of a dream
signals a deep crisis inside the left
that cannot be underestimated it is an
existential problem that leaves it
without an achievable goal the past
Notions of socialist Utopias are
unraveling in a woke nightmare of
identity politics and IR rational
discourse that attracts no one
celebrities are leaving the left because
there is nothing left to appeal to their
rational Minds the Socialist agenda is
hollow unwelcoming and incoherent for
all its defects the rightest vision
still seeks beautiful dreams it can
always appeal to that audacious dream of
an order turned toward Christ that so
transformed the
West this is this is fun this is fun but
obviously any leftist post rouso is
going to look at the quote highly
attractive historical accomplishments
and cultural developments unquote and be
like look at the mode of production that
produced this if you were born there
chances are 95 out of a 100 you're a
slave but instead of dealing with any of
that no it's uh we don't have the
capacity to dream this is a the paranoia
fantasy that we just don't like
Christianity not that we're opposed to
slavery it's amazing that how politics
is so close to religion here like that's
the the state of the political discourse
remember how great everything used to be
when everyone just believed in Jesus if
only I could go back and be born a
sharecropper I wouldn't have to deal
with looking at a woman being the main
character of Lord of the
Rings it wasn't great for everybody at
all a narrow group of people at the top
of society like pico deir andola was a
noble it's puzzling though because I
mean I'm just I'm just like kind of
browsing through the different articles
I was just looking at the culture
section and then now I'm looking at the
section that they call Republic right
which to me right away when people start
using that word like American religious
people you know that there's some sort
of weird worshipping of the American
Republic system and I don't know like
it's just it's strange I mean I need to
read one of these articles and I did
just open one up where they're saying
like you know what the Federalist really
said so they're talking about the
Federalist Papers um but it's just
puzzling to me that these like hardcore
Christians like the weird the weird
Fusion between Christian fundamentalism
and like a weird almost quasi religious
worshipping of like the Declaration of
Independence because so many of the
American founding documents I feel like
kind of set the stage for a lot of the
stuff that they hate like I I don't know
it's just like like how do they keep
those two things I mean they might be
really critical like and there were kind
of signs in the three articles that I
read actually where they didn't
necessarily love the American system and
obviously we can't assume that all the
writers agree with each other but it's
just a little puzzling to me that they
and the fact but the fact that they even
have a section on the on the website
called Republic like just to me that is
a sign of some kind of reverence for the
American Constitution and the American
constitutional system which to me like
swws the seeds of the very like
degradation of culture that they're
talking about I mean there's so I mean
even back then but all of history right
instrumentalizing religion for political
purposes has been an enormous yeah you
know and the opposite too using religion
for purposes of critiquing power right
it's it happens both ways all the time
and you know this is this is a very not
self-critical kind of thing when you use
it in the service of power or you use it
in the service of your own politic iCal
views you say well my political views
are on the side of you know we have God
on our side and they the Godless
leftists and the Godless socialists like
look what the damage they're doing to
the world like it's so you know it's
such an old tired argument but it it
keeps working it's a perennial one it
comes back in different forms it's a
Hydra you know and and in the end it it
never works but I mean I guess it does
work sometimes in the sense that you
know it does have an effect and but I
always think that that it's a negative
effect right but you know using it in
the service of
promoting whatever conservative
political views is probably not the most
uh it's probably a bit of a sin in
itself but you you'd be hardpressed to
convince these kinds of people of that
the left that they're objecting to is
not really what we'd call the left it's
just
anyone left of them which includes
liberalism tolerance is bad because if
if if we're tolerant of everything then
a soup can is Art instead of you know
David Michelangelo's David being
considered art but it's so it's so
strange because then I wonder what what
is your purpose in the are you trying to
change the rest of the world and the
rest of culture because that's better
which is they think it's just hitting
the rewind button but be beyond that
what is your purpose are you trying to
convert people to your cause like
ostensibly that's kind of the goal here
but why do you even need to do that and
this is kind of where I'm confused about
you know what does it take for Christ to
return does the world have to be in
order or does Christ come back after the
world has gotten so bad that there's
nothing else to fix I don't understand
what they think their civilizational
argument is even for or doing except to
say the Aesthetics or Aesthetics
cultural Aesthetics used to be better
before and now they're bad and from
where I'm sitting this is not just
irrelevant to Christianity but actually
hostile to Christianity because I read
what Christ said in the Bible I don't I
don't know that he ever spoke about
Aesthetics at all because this would
belong to the category of the things of
this world and the things of this world
are fundamentally in conflict with the
stuff he talks about in terms of God's
kingdom or the kingdom to come I think
it's a
pathology yeah I mean it's a good
question and I just have so little
insight into it because I just grew up
in such a non that that for me to get
inside the head of a Christian like I
feel like maybe I just have no idea
because I cannot get into their heads oh
I I wouldn't know either I'd have to
speculate
I think just you know the only way I
could i' have this is this is Matthew
mcmanis territory yeah but I suspect
it's it's pathological you know not
saying we we all have our pathologies
yes and this is one of them you know
being this kind of character type they
probably are super down with with you
know a conservative form of
authoritarianism but not a leftist not
one they would perceive as leftist you
know and they probably think West is the
best and everyone else is dog [__] and
and I mean that's a that's a certain
pathology and then you sprinkle some you
know religion on top of that so they are
leftwing Catholics and they are they're
they're just like there are right-wing
Jews and there are leftwing Jews or
left-wing atheists right-wing atheists
it's all like I mean I don't want to
reduce everything to pathology there's
there's history there's circumstance
there's all kinds of other things too
but but you know it's it goes a long way
I think to if I'm while I'm wildly
speculating with little evidence those
are the places I would start
looking yeah I agree this definitely
sounds to me like they want
a they want the the political order to
be the
church right is that fair to say like a
certain vision of it well is it just is
it just about saving Souls then is it
just I don't think so I don't don't
think so I think they
want something that resembles a Theo
theocracy because that's also the best
thing for human flourishing here on
Earth and again I'm confused as to how
that fits with the religion because of
all the you know my kingdom is not of
this world and that kind of stuff but
they seem to want some sort of political
Theocratic body that is instantiated
here on Earth especially to make sure
that art
is good art their version of good art
instead of what's happening now it's bad
the way to fix it is to hit the rewind
button and to find our universal truth
that has been you know delivered by
Christ and then by all these other
thinkers who who discovered it somehow
in the extraneous literature and by by
reading books as opposed to reading
ebooks which is bad so yeah I have no
understanding really what they think
history is
for because you wouldn't really need to
push an agenda because pushing agenda
wouldn't Advance your agenda which is
not of this world I would think or they
think they can redeem This World by
reversing the decline of religion and
Christianity which is taking place
because of secular liberalism which has
been enshrined
in even and especially the states that
they like like God this is incoherent
but maybe I'm missing something I don't
know it's quite incoherent yeah did
anyone else pick up on like uh in the
original article that you linked this
review of that book uh you know he's
talking well first there's like a really
funny critique of John rolls that like I
don't have to get into but maybe I will
mean reason faith and the struggle for
Western Civilization that book yeah yeah
exactly um there's a funny critique that
he quotes of John rolls but then right
after that he's talking about um the
final Lo and logical upshot of the
materialist worldview is either an
amoral nihilism that seeks only personal
pleasure or a Sentimental relativism
that says that everybody has his or her
own view of what is good and that
everybody just ought to be nice to
everyone else and then he says Dr
esselon identifies the former ISM with
the male of the species and the second
with the female oh so we're we're two
we're too feminized yeah well no but he
says that the relativism is the feminine
one and the and the nihilism is the is
the masculine one so being a nihilist is
masculine but being a relativist is
feminine so the the schopenhauer man
versus the Hillary Clinton liberal I
guess so I guess I don't know I just
thought it was kind of amusing that like
he he just throws in that again you can
criticize you
know the equality of every belief system
under the law which is what he's
presumably talking about so should they
not be equal under the law they never
come out and say that part but is that I
guess is that's what what's intended
yeah I don't know I mean so this the
critique of John rolls might be relevant
here because like and this is a book
review by the way so he's kind of going
through and he's like oh Dr eel esalon's
firm faith in an experience of our
essentially communal Humanity which he
positions between the radical
individualism of the extreme right and
the anti-humanist collectivism of the
left could offer the following much
needed critique and deflation of the
fashionable philosopher uh John rolls
and then like he goes on his description
of John rolls is like I guess he's
talking about like the veil of ignorance
right where like you know you can't uh
you have to there's problems with the
veil of ignorance right but basically
the idea is okay you you you have to
like reason about well I don't know what
my social position in society is going
to be right so from that perspective I
should try to think like what would be
fair terms that I would accept right if
I didn't know like I might wake up and
end up being like a black disabled woman
or I could be like a rich white guy
right so it's like we need to think
about well if you don't know then what
would be like a fair way of organizing
society and so the way that this guy
describes it is he says uh he asks us
nay he demands it of us under pain of
banishment from Civic discourse that we
pretend that we are not Sons and
Daughters fathers and mothers husbands
and wives neighbors and members of a
community in this place and not another
worshiping God in this church and in
these ways and devoted to a certain
vision of the good a vision that we do
not deduce from abstract principles but
either see intuitively or experience in
the blood he requires Us in short not to
be human at all and only then H or only
in so far as we can adopt the pose of
the bloodless and desiccated may we may
we come together to form a contract a
profoundly antisocial contract dictating
civil rights punishment
and so and like dude it was a thought
experiment it was a thought experiment
here's the just Society imagine you're
anyone yeah not oh yeah you're nobody
you're a bloodless floating Spirit
society as if you could be one of the
worst off so M you better make one of
the worst off like not so bad and that
this is this is essentially the reaction
to that thought experiment that's what I
was thinking when I read this too
exactly it's like you mean not part of a
family with a specific tradition how is
that your Rea that I mean that's again
that's the the sort of mind at work here
is just completely inappropriate
reactions to things this is so dark cu
the next line after that after what you
just read is like this makes this book
worth reading yeah no he's like that
paragraph alone makes the book worth
reading graph alone it's like okay oh my
God birds of a feather holy [__] isn't
this part part of Christian charity to
like think of think of the think of the
worst off to you know like that's what I
to say I was poor I was hungry and you
fed me I was in prison and you visited
me like that kind of [__] doesn't Jesus
come up in this uh discussion at all yes
it's very humanist well that's what I
was thinking too because I was like no
no like your misunderstanding he's
actually not asking you to pretend
you're no one he's pretending he's
actually trying to get you to think
about like other people like that's
literally like just think of other
how about you think about other people
and it's like you're asking me to think
about not being a churchgoing person
like how dare you that means that you're
thinking of me not being a human being
it's like just think about other people
how about like Jesus taught you it's
like an in it's like a sympathy
blindness it's like they they're unable
to empathize with other people and in
fact actively offended when they are
asked to empathize with people who are
not them or not like them and it's it's
very strange
it's very strange so hold UPS as an
anti-humanist in this way is is very
strange to me he goes on to say uh
materialism he argues is a bankrupt
worldview that kills Wonder gratitude
and friendship reducing man to a handful
of mud that can be shaped and reshaped
at will by the autonomous individual and
amorphous State um the materialist may
be claimed to be guided by goodness or
Justice or duty but his system cannot
provide a foundation for any of these
things so being concerned with like the
equal
distribution of you know Essentials like
access to water and food and air and
clothing and shelter like that's
materialism here that heavily
heavy-handedly calling that
materialism and thinking that those
relatively equally distributed is sort
of inhuman like you're asking people not
to be humans when you want the world to
be like sort of relatively equal like
that and it's yeah you're were saying
that like uh it's so bad to think about
other people you're making me think
about like you're you're trying to make
me not be a selfish [__] and like
that's destroying everything that means
to be human I know that's not that's fre
it's my freedom to be a selfish jackass
and like try to acrew as much wealth as
possible which which may mean I'll have
to take bread from out of hungry
people's mouths in order to realize my
Humanity you're asking me to not do that
it's it's God maybe we need to read this
book oh my God can I just read these two
sentences come right next to each other
right relativism is nihilism for girls
yeah exactly end of end of paragraph
then the next paragraph says our only
hope to counter this freef fall and
remember relativism is just imagine you
were born as the worst person in societ
Society how would you want to be treated
right that's what relativism is our only
hope to counter this freef fall into
nalism and relativism is a return to
reality not the false reality of the
materialists but the true reality of
those who worship the word the only way
to become real is to join ourselves to
Christ who gives us our being by his
love oh my co ravaged lungs can't handle
it Christ's love is do not make me think
of other people yeah Christ wasn't you
know there was I thought it was
interesting there was a decree I just
read I forget which century it was
definitely early modern decree from the
Catholic church that the on the poverty
of Christ this is what it was called the
poverty of Christ and they called it
heretical to believe that the poverty of
Christ was literal that like wealth is
kind of a sin and the Catholic Church
Church there's a Papal bow deciding on
this debate about the poverty of Christ
and it decided in favor of yeah like
wealth is not a sin you know Christ
poverty was like his decision I guess
basically of course the [__] Pope
would say that from his gold guilded
Throne getting Poverty of Christ
Vibes I know the thing I know the bull
you're talking about and it was written
in response to I think it was like late
Middle Ages maybe during the aen
papacy um but this guy I think maybe a
Franciscan wrote a
track that was viscerally critical of
the Catholic church and I think it's
called the poverty of the Apostles
something like that and it says stuff
like uh remember Christ and his
followers who slept under the stars and
then compare it to these priests or
these uh Church of officials who go to
bed in their golden beds and then
compare compare them or Christ walking
barefoot in the dirt to these priest off
or these Church officials riding their
horses that are covered in gold and he
wrote this whole thing back and forth
like compare the way they're living to
those who they purport to emulate and
then the response is no the poverty
doesn't have to be literal and they
eventually threw him in prison for being
a heretic yeah cuz you had the
franciscans who were like uh taking vows
of poverty and so yeah yeah so this was
like late Middle Ages early 14th century
yeah you had the Franciscan order sort
of living Christ's life like that like
imitating his poverty his having no
possessions you know people would join
The Franciscan order sometimes like Rich
folk would do it and like give up all
their worldly possessions and the yeah
Pope John the 22nd declared it a
heretical Doctrine to promote the
poverty of Christ as yeah like so it's
means it's kind of a spiritual poverty
yeah that's let's just forget you know
blessed are the meek they will be
comforted blessed are the poor the eye
of the camel through the eye of the
needle thing right it's harder to get
into heaven for a rich person than it
would be to put the camel through the
eye of the needle is that how it goes
probably not word for word yeah
something like that the amount of
citations you could give to Jesus
talking about wealth as opposed to the
zero times that Jesus all that was
figurative the zero times that he talks
about like
homosexuality that was all metaphorical
dude it meant it meant you know acrew as
much wealth as possible [__] your
neighbor that's what it meant just in
spirit you have to be po poor and and
charitable let's just finish up this
awesome article I love I I love I love
this honestly the materialist may not
believe in hell but he does not have to
he has already built it on
Earth uh Dr esselin would free us from
that man-made hell and return us to the
word created world where goodness truth
and Beauty are real and can be
known like amen mephistophiles and Dr
Fus all right is anyone uh you guys want
to convert we can take your confession
your first confession right
here no no no
after discovering this website I am much
further from converting than I was
before so congratulations on doing the
Lord's work do you know that when I was
a little kid my dad took me into a
church to just show me like what like
just to give me some cultural
understanding and like he tried to give
me commu or he was like I guess they
were all lining up to take their
communion Wafers or whatever and uh I
don't actually remember this but he
always told me the story and I like
lined up and when I got there the priest
was like I guess I'm not allowed if
you're too young or something something
like that so he was like he was like no
you can't take it because like I I don't
know why I was just like a little kid
and then so my dad got in line and then
like took it and pretended to put it in
his mouth and then actually gave it to
me later didn't Jesus say like do not do
not prevent the children from coming to
me yeah exactly and then I like how my
dad stole the communion wafer and
pretended to like and then just cuz I
think I was like a little [__] and like
I was crying cuz I wanted the snack like
I thought it would be like delicious and
it was actually just like a shitty wafer
I've had a Catholic communion wafer I
think I'm not supposed to take it cuz
you have to be taken into the church
somehow through some ritual but they're
really gross they taste like a like a
flavorless rice cracker yeah I think
don't they like stick to the roof of
your mouth they're kind of like uh kind
of like the same material that like
those you remember those little candies
that were like a styrofoam thing that
had all the sour powder inside it's
definitely yeah it tastes like Styrofoam
for sure yeah I've NE never tasted the
the the body you've never tasted the
body of Christ I've never had that's
that's what that's what that Professor
that I that was my parents friend must
have meant e that like uh that's what he
wanted to meant by participating in the
body of Christ you know taking the way
for if I wanted that I could just order
a package and put some packing peanuts
in my mouth Body of Christ exactly
exactly all right why don't we leave it
there this I don't know like this is
actually I I it was funny to read but it
comes off really dark we should send uh
we should send it to the to some of the
writers our podcast and be like hey do
you want to come on sometime here's what
we thought yeah I want I want to get uh
do esselin I got esselin Dr esselin sex
and the unreal City the demolition of
the western
mind they'll crush us with their
right-wing network of think tanks and
dark money I wonder how many how many
people read this
blog I mean there's a lot of post so I
mean the people are the people they're
reviewing I don't know if the reviewers
are are I I haven't looked into them but
you know like some of the authors that
they're reviewing there's quite a few
like ivly authors on here right yeah I'm
looking at the about meet the editors
too and I'm just like seeing W Winston
Elliot thei holy [__] oh my
[Laughter]
God he's and guess what founder
publisher and editor-in chief the
founder of course the founder would be
someone named W Winston Elliot III this
is a super anglosaxon name he might be a
convert to Catholicism definitely the
name of a true soldier in the army of
Western Civilization that's why I say if
we just became like a right-wing podcast
and started like asking the Heartland
Institute for money we would we could we
would just be rich we could just
capitulate and we'd be we'd be [__]
laughing all the way to the bank
conservatives love those stories of the
convert right the who
becomes crossing the aisle and they're
like oh my God what was it like to be a
left Wier and now like youve become
you've seen the light the world as
illuminated by true Christian love and
charity
yeah all right we we bless you all we
wish you Christ's sanctifying love to
God keep you
and keep you and and bless
you and God be with you there we go
amen amen
[Music]
[__]